[موسيقى]
هذه المشاهد الساحره والجبال التي تكتسي
تماما باللون الاخضر هي جزء من جزيره
تيردي او جزيره الارض المرتفعه واحده من
اجمل جزر الكاريب الواقعه في خليج غواد
يعيش هنا نحو الفي شخص فقط على مساحه تبلغ
نحو خمسه الاف كيلومتر مربع
امام اعينهم مشهد بديع للبحر واليخوت
والقوارب وخلفهم جبال شاهقه مغطاه
بالاشجار ايقاع الحياه هنا هادئ ومثالي
للغايه حتى انه استقطب بعض الفنانين
والمبدعين للاستقرار والعيش في الجزيره
فنان فرنسي وقع في حب هذه الجزيره وضعها
قائبه على ارضها ولم يغادرها منذ 27 عاما
هذا الفضاء كان مثاليا بالنسبه لي روح
الجزر المغلقه في خليج جميل كهذا انها
المساحه التي كنت بحاجتها
قصه حب من نوع فريد اكتملت هنا بين ادوارد
وقوارب الصيد القديمه المهجوره على الشاطئ
[موسيقى]
ما احبه حقا في هذه القوارب هو العلامات
التي تركها الزمن علامات رحلات الصيد تاكل
الخشب والطلاء نعم انه امر رائع حقا
واعتقد انه يبوح بكامل حياه الصيادين وهو
شيء يعني الكثير بالنسبه لي انه لامر مثير
جدا للاهتمام
المواد التي صنع منها انها جميله جدا جدا
جدا جميله
هذه الاخشاب الباليه ياخذها كلود معه الى
الاستوديو الذي يعمل به ثم يحولها الى
اعمال فنيه ويبث فيها الحياه من جديد
هدوء الجزيره ينتهي كل يوم في نفس التوقيت
عندما تصل العباره السياحيه محمله بالزائر
لينتشروا في اراضي وشواطئ تيردي هذا
الخليج مصنف ضمن اجمل الخلجان في العالم
لذلك يصل نحو 200 الف سائح سنويا الى هذه
الجزيره الصغيره ونتيجه لذلك فان معظم
السكان هنا تكيفوا مع الوضع وطوروا
خدماتهم المقدمه للسياح عندما وصلت الى
هنا قبل 27 عاما بدات اشعر بالقلق قليلا
من اعداد السياح وبدات اتساءل ما هل ستكبر
اعداد السياحه الذين سياتون الى الجزيره
لكن في النهايه بقيت الاعداد معقوله
[موسيقى]
القداس الاسبوعي صباح يوم الاحد هو
المناسبه الوحيده التي تجمع سكان الجزيره
يلتقي السكان هنا على وقع اجراس الكنيسه
لاداء الصلوات ثم يستانفون حياتهم لخدمه
السياح والاستمتاع بجزيرتهم
[موسيقى]